I'm here with Meg Gill who's the
co-founder and president of golden road
brewing which is tell me exactly is the
largest brewery in Southern California
the only brewery in Southern California
oh no no way there were there a lot of
great breweries but we're just a very
fast growing new brewery in LA there
were lots of breweries in San Diego
actually over 70 but in LA when we
started packaging our cans two years ago
we were the first packaged brewery so
beer available at a grocery store or
liquor store in a ten million person
radius of LA County so that was the
opportunity that got me down to LA my
partner had owned a beer bar that was
doing very well and saw the saw the
demand for you know a need for for a
brewery and you said you were saying
that was all about fresh beer it's all
about getting a beer from the brewery to
the customer quickly yeah quickly and
you know in the best practices of
getting the beer from the fermentation
tanks into the vessel that you're going
to consume it in so we we chose feel
free drink from that you'd like I
believe that is an IPA called quaked
away
point the way IPA yeah yeah so this this
beer we decided to put in aluminum cans
protects the beer from light strike and
oxidation that happens in glass bottles
so you've had some really kind of
incredible successes so with all food
products as I'm sure you will know
distribution is the game but you've
gotten into Whole Foods you said Costco
Dodger Stadium
that's incredible how did you how did
you how did that happen how did you make
that happen well you're asking me about
my classics degree she studied classics
at Yale which seems to me a long
classics the beer but maybe not a little
Plato a little yeah you know well well
Latin is about putting pieces of a
puzzle together and the same thing is
true you're getting your beer in a shelf
it's all about like finding those
relationships and those people to help
support the story behind the the beer
the beer itself and the product so you
know I can see
it takes a lot to get the beer onto the
shelf but as as long as you're willing
to put yourself out there and find the
right people and resources to get the
beer there that's that's how we've been
successful you were also or are a very
competitive swimmer you you were you
want set a bunch of Records at Yale you
talked a little bit about that and how
that's informed your business experience
sure I love the sport of swimming I
still swim almost every day and you know
that passion has just kind of changed
from what was almost my full-time job in
training to Olympic Trials to that that
passion kind of coming into the beer
business swimming the discipline and the
passion is kind of what I've just
changed into focus in the beer and the
business so it's great to have the
balance of both I still swim for the
Olympic Club and they've been supporting
my swimming basically since I graduated
from Yale so I have a great network that
that that helps me go around the world
and swim and and sell beer as well so
and what is the biggest misconception do
you think that people have about the the
beer or the booze business that then
it's easy well because it but it seems
like it's like a lot of fun right and
maybe and I'm sure it's a tremendous
amount of hard work it is you know the
the beer industry is is the craft beer
industry is is all about passion and the
stories behind these these remarkable
smaller brands so you know we bring we
bring like a small product to life on
the shelf and there's a lot of steps
between making the beer even sourcing
the grains and the hops and getting the
beer on the Shelf that I think a lot of
people may take for granted may not and
you were earlier you were saying
something they were that I thought was
amazing apparently I've been drinking
beer wrong my entire life so the
appropriate amount of head-on the IPA
that your you're drinking now you said
is two and a half fingers yeah so you
know I was measuring out the the
appropriate head
I have advising you're gonna want a
little more a little more head on our
point the way IPA usually do like two
two and 1/2 fingers gets the aroma out
but
ran out of glasses so I'm going to
straight from the can so where are you
gonna be in five years are you gonna
still be running the brewery you and and
and expanding you're only in Southern
California right now right yeah so we're
just in SoCal I hope to be continuing to
do what I'm doing you know the LA market
is six million barrels of beer we're one
quarter of one percent of that market
currently so hopefully in five years
we'll have a little bit more of that
market share and continue to bring craft
beer in the culture craft beer to the
community thank you so much back yeah
thank you
cherish throughs